Rishi Sunak is hours away from being sworn in...
...as Britain's third prime minister in two months.
The former chancellor represents an historic change in UK politics,...
...becoming the first leader of Asian descent.
He's also the first resident of Downing Street...
...to be twice as rich as the King.
At 42, Rishi Sunak is the youngest British prime minister...
...in more than two centuries.
Oxford educated, a career in finance.
In many ways, the father of two represents the Tory establishment.
But he is a significant break from the past.
The first British prime minister of Indian background.
The first who is a practicing Hindu.
The fact that this is possible now, in 2022,...
...is a new thing in British politics.
That wouldn't have been the case even ten years ago,...
...and certainly not 20 years ago.
He's also likely to be the wealthiest person to call 10 Downing Street home.
His wife, Akshata Murthy, is the daughter of one of India's richest men.
The couple's net worth is put at more than 1.3 billion Australian dollars.
Quite a rise for a man who only entered Parliament seven years ago.